foreign
[Applause]
the people of ladakh are determined to
make their voices heard many have
traveled a thousand kilometers to New
Delhi to demand their rights
we have protested in Jammu and ladakh
earlier but nobody listened to us that's
why we have to come to Delhi so the
government can hear our voice
protesters say they want a separate
State and their jobs and land to be
protected
Constitution has a special provision
called the sixth schedule that protects
eras with tribal and Indigenous peoples
it's been applied to four states in the
Northeast most people in ladakh belong
to these communities and while they have
wanted more autonomy for a long time
their demands have intensified over the
past two years
nestled in the Himalayas ladakh is part
of the larger Kashmir region claimed in
full by India and Pakistan Kashmir is
governed by both Nations and parts in
August 2019 the governing BJP party
revoked its special status and brought
it under the governance of New Delhi
ladakh became a union territory
infrastructure projects by New Delhi
have sparked fears of interference and
concerns about environmental damage in
the ecologically sensitive area people
say local administrators now have fewer
powers and ladakh was better off before
our lane was protected our jobs were
protected and now we are totally exposed
to outside influence
ah in that way we were much better
but we wanted separation of ladakh from
Jammu and Kashmir
but we didn't want it in this way the
BJP says ladakh doesn't need a separate
state to protect its residents
nobody is going to settle here nobody
has come to settle here and this is just
a rumor by the opposition to you know
misled the people of ladakh no
Democratic demographic change has taken
place so far and this will not happen
and we are there to assure you
[Applause]
the government has formed a committee to
address concerns of the protesters but
they say they'll only take part in talks
if their core demands are put on the
agenda mythology New Delhi